au total on a supprimé 69 mille lits ces
quinze dernières années
rien qu'en 2018 on a supprimé 4172 lit
ça représente à peu près 1% par an de
suppression on l'a vu avec le co vide
nous n'avions pas les capacitaire pour
prendre en charge les patients
puisqu'ils ont été transférés pour
certains en allemagne en belgique
donc franchement là la santé va mal en
france
il va falloir se poser se poser
sérieusement sur les conditions de
travail des professionnels de santé
on a beaucoup de professionnels qui vont
quitter la fonction publique et qui vont
s'orienter dans d'autres domaines
puisque là si rien n'est fait c'est ce
qui va se passer